why hi this is the Sadashiva pipe from
science mission so today we have a
doctor
Paulo Suzanne Korsak croci with the
Donald brand professor and director at
center of epigenetics metabolism in the
biological chemistry School of Medicine
at UC Irvine with us here is won several
awards to his credit I'm going to
mention only three of them because it
will take forever to mention all of them
so he has a long history of winning
several awards one of them in 2011 he
won he spent award in endocrinology from
France again in 2011 so he became the
external member max planck society from
germany in 2012 he won transatlantic
medal of the Society for endocrinology
from UK in 2013 he won dr. Henry
Feinstein plenary lecture he gave the
award lecture in Canada in 2014 he
became the fellow of American society
Association for advancement of Sciences
the USA is triple EAS society and in
2015 he won August and Mary Crowe medal
from Denmark welcome dr. Rossi to the
Hangout can you please talk about
yourself your background etc very
British Lee I interest into science when
I was young we both telescope in there
the very first thing we did was to I
think we were 10 individuals old first
thing we did was to point to the sky and
in the first object we saw was Saturn
and that I think was that the click the
little thing that changed my mind and
like wow this is fascinating that's
that's what I want to do is to study
science mm-hmm
yes I that's how I started then later on
I went to I had to pick one direction
one school University I decided to do
for biology
I got excited about DNA and and that was
you know really remarkable I had no idea
at that time being maybe was 1718 I was
gonna go and have lunch with Francis
Crick this obviously continues later so
that how I started and I I will never
change my mind I mean I think it was the
best job in the world I can wake up in
the morning and decide what I want to do
you know what experiment I think is fun
nothing better than that
ok and the fella Bobby you are a lab
black people right so the lab is so
since about oh wow it's crazy scary to
say about almost 30 years I have a lab
first in France for about 20 years I was
in France
where my first mentor Pierson bone had
given me the opportunity to start my own
lab after my postdoc at silk and since I
started my lab I was being blessed by
having number of exceptional
postdoctoral fellows I counted a total
of probably 170 was then to say many of
them are wearing our exceptional people
and they're now having their own career
some of them very successful career so
I'm really be blessed I also had many
exceptional PhD students that I would to
say that my lab has been mostly a
postdoc lab for years okay so my lab is
basically a new place to be my personal
you know the my best success and I and I
could say that above all the possible
scientific achievements or words that
you were listening before my my number
was a success been to treat a lab where
the atmosphere is a good atmosphere
people are well which are their friends
they spend time together
our night together and I think that is
my my real success so one of the things
is the mentoring so what is your
mentoring philosophy how do you mentor
these people like I know this has to go
up and down so you need to like it's
hard sometimes you have to deal with
well number one you have to deal with
fellows from everywhere in the world I
have in Europe from Japan from India
from South America you know really from
everywhere so you end up basically with
a group of people are extremely diverse
in their culture in their psychology
which is great because that means they
can really connect each other
on the other hand it's kind of
complicated because each one of them is
gonna have his own psychological mental
requirements and requests obviously so
my mentoring is well first of all if you
don't if you love we do which is that
which I do then you care for the people
that's one thing just caring for them
say yeah I don't see them as you know
passengers I see them as a form of a
family or being together and working
together I'm fun together obviously they
are up announced as you mentioned
sometime the paper not is not accepted
some sometimes someone didn't get the
fellowship and so there are moments
where boo stocks can be you know going
down and be frustrated fact is that
everyone here knows that that is their
time of life it's the key moment in the
life to then move from the postdoctoral
space to independent investigator so
they need to be successful so it work
really hard but they also know that you
know it's not easy is it's not to be
successful you know just because you
work hard that you're successful but one
thing is clear that if you don't work
hard you clearly not gonna be successful
so that's that's there my mentoring is
mostly based on on you know leading by
example I work hard but to me is our
work is for
so I work hard but at the same time I
try to have a balanced life doing sports
like music you know I try to you know
ever the people in my lab as well you
know invested in that so we often have
parties picnics outdoor activities that
creates and cement lab strongly so they
feel part of the group not they're not
isolated individuals so overall has been
working pretty fine I cannot complain
okay and let's talk about the some of
the projects you are doing and how you
got interested in circadian rhythm so
that it was almost by serendipity like
the best things in life they all happen
when you don't move don't expect him
yeah at the time in fact I'll mentioned
that during my presentation we work in a
transcription factor called cram that we
discovered something like 27 20 years
ago and dies a factor that controls near
endocrine responses in genes they are
responsive to cyclic AMP in itself
through signaling pathways at the time I
had a postdoc in the lab wanted to know
what was the expression would be but
this really go gene in the brain and I
felt there was a who cares mostly but
she's like why okay just go and do it
and he come up with a picture that I'll
show during my presentation that to me
was like what really in this factory was
a highly expressed in the pineal gland
but during night time not doing the
reason for that is because I asked my
technician to repeat the experiment and
while the postdoc will sacrifice the
mice at night she was sacrificed and why
I said a time I felt both were wrong or
something was in the alleys they were
both right the only thing that changed
was the postdoc who was working at night
and technician priceless I was there in
the morning so we see this difference
and that was the beginning of a whole
journey that's still ongoing and I feel
is exciting and
that difference really tells us at the
time he told us that on that factor
controls a single enzyme the melatonin
pathway
it controls melatonin synthesis so we
felt like wow we're linking a
transcriptional regulation to a hormonal
production and we felt that was
particularly exciting at the time the
last started seriously ideas and things
to do my background is a background in
gene expression in epigenetics so I try
to connect everything I see in in in
executing field with that idea behind my
mind so really linking metabolism to
epigenetics that's why we have a center
here that is a special Center
specialized Center built here on purpose
for us but school medicine and it's
called the Center for epigenetics in the
power okay so now you can present your
work like on the circadian rhythm if you
don't mind let's try yeah alright I can
start if you want any time yes you're
good though down here at the Center for
judgment as I just mentioned is under
Tucker this building on the campus of
the UCI and this is a picture of the
grip super recent the concepts who we
like to really approach or what they
have to do with how environment and
nutrition are talking to homeostasis now
the concept of miss thesis I'll mention
in a second originally indicated by
Claude Bernard famous philosopher from
France was that nothing in biology is
fixed but everything is somehow cyclic
so to adapt to changes in the
environment to adapt to possible inputs
for the external world when we talked
about several world we're talking about
obviously here the light-dark cycle
nutrition exercise
or let's say drugs of abuse so what we
have discovered in the past several
years is that a good part of Mississippi
genetic control is driven by this
routine o'clock now let's talk about
epigenetics for a second and I like to
show this picture is a picture of the
Kobe Bryant famous player basketball
here from LA
someone who trained it on campus your
UCI for many years I was talk to him at
the coffee shop he speaks perfect
Italian because his dad was playing in
Italy and he grew up in Italy so people
are all surprised to see Kobe talked
into this Italian guy but what is really
cool here is that Kobe is tall exactly
six point five feet which is two meters
that is exactly how much DNA we have in
every cell there's a lot of DNA in every
nucleus the nucleus is only ten micron
in order to have all that DNA compact in
the Nicholas you need to go through a
complex mechanism is chromatin
compaction is shown here we go from the
DNA that is using the new clothes Oh
miss is a basic protein structure and
I'll tell you a little bit more about
new consume in a second and then the
super capacity of the DNA to compact
itself leads to the structuring of a
chromosome we're really DNA is compacted
in a way that the question we all have
and are just made but many other people
in the field is as a possible such a
complexity Noam is able to allow for
transcriptional activation or silencing
these are specific for time in response
to physiological stimuli now what really
happens that each nickel Zuma's is
composed by four histones and itchy
stone has a tail and these tails are in
terminal tails stick out from the nickel
dome structure and with these tails are
nothing else than platforms where
different types of post translational
modification can occur when we're
talking about methylation
phosphorylation acetylation law now the
enzymes that do the job of adding one of
those particular group let's say that's
a tool group are called writers there's
the enzyme that will put the asset over
the one we're removing it would be the
erasers it will be
one that will take it away so a writer
for acetyl group is an acetyl
transferase and the eraser will be a
deacetylase so just for example for a
metal group will be able to transferase
or a demi-glace now the point that I
want to make here and it is a take
center about our interests in the center
the way of here on campus is that um
these enzymes in order to function
properly and to add this virus possible
modification you need to read
metabolites or even use them
specifically for example the in order to
get us two groups on the DNA or sort of
chromosomes and histones you need a
little quiet she's the key source of
acid groups as well for us from metal
groups you need Sam Battalion the key
metabolite in a tiny pathway this is the
single donor of metal group in itself
the appropriate metabolites at the right
time the right place in the cell in
order to get those modifications so we
like to use the concept that armed the
chromatin backbone works for the sensing
cellar metabolism and maybe even
contributing to cell metabolism meaning
back or utilizing those metabolites so
based on this concept the question is
where does metabolites come from and
this comes from from all this beautiful
Mike biochemical pathway studies so on
at school well we discovered in the past
a few years if you do metabolomics it is
an approach to look at all possible
metabolize you can see my mass
spectrometry in the cell if you go up to
about tazza metabolites for each cell
each type of tissue at different time
day or night
where will we discover that 50 percent
of metabolites or zucchini
they're not flat they're actually
oscillating and doing a nice cycle this
is particularly in the liver we haven't
created as specialized bio computing
interface cost economics this is a
computing allows to everyone is totally
free to everybody
anyone wants to know whether their
favorite metabolite is present or not
present where the person day and night
what time a day or whatever in every
dish you there were single South you
want all that information is my country
resource well what we discovered that's
the concept is that 50% of metabolizers
Kenan thereby 50% less or metabolism
zucchini and that means what is really
circadian what is what it means now the
word circadian comes from Sirte diem in
Latin and I'd like to show this picture
for a reason life started on his planet
something like 4 billion years ago and a
way that life started in all possible
biological circuits were created and
generated Israel the result of this
revolution and what we call history the
past twelve thousand years it's really a
little bit of time compared to the West
I'd like to compare this to money people
think about money better than years
we're gonna compare four billion dollars
to twelve thousand dollars that's the
difference we talk about when the past
hundred fifty dollars hundred fifteen
years we generated in our culture
logical like television cars internet
Facebook or whatever our things are
really dramatically changing our biology
those circuits have been established
over the past four million years are now
addition now why the different because
there's things yeah
today the modern society is impacting on
something that's been there forever what
he's been there for everybody's been
there that it was really almost
unchanged since life starts in this
planet this is the rotation of our own
planet on its own axis now because we
have 23.5 degrees inclined axis that's
why we have but this rotation 24-hour
rotation of hurt on its stone axes has
been basically the same in the past at
least one or two billion years it's
being slowing down but still the life
has started in
adapted to these cycles over a long time
so we gotta take this into account in
fact isn't this we should accept the
idea if that's the case most likely
circadian rhythms mr. keating biology
must be dominant in many life forms and
as I'll tell you in a minute that's
exactly what happens 15 rhythms are
common to most life forms on the planet
because it's so such an ancient system
so the original observations came from
this fellow from France Jacques the man
to this fellow
well before our times 200 years ago
almost observed that this is planned to
the hell the truck will change the
opening and closing of the leaves during
the day the night now this is something
that immediately felt like some effect
of light but he did one experiment that
I think was the key experiment for the
field still today is that if I'd put the
plant computing could use darkness so
now there's no more effective light the
plant was still a shell these
oscillations opening and closing the
loops but this is telling you that is an
intrinsic system inside the plant for
instant animals that shows that
securities are intrinsic to the animal
they're not necessarily driven by die
gamers or effects from the outside I'll
tell you in a minute so there is an
intrinsic clock to every single life
form on the planet is intrinsic clock is
able to function independently from
outside stimuli how common is this
Desai's planet well the concept Omiya
station which entities before also came
from this fellow called Bernard and I
say the physiology is cyclic the man
like in all possible organisms and the
fellows he has shown our key fellows in
the field I will say that the father or
the brood is really similar benzo super
beds in 1971 published this paper in
PNAS together with the wrong cannot
the change because his idea was that
somehow all behavior must be having a
genetic background meaning some type of
a genetic basis if that's the case you
have to find genes the will change the
sort of connectivity of a fly and indeed
together with Ron kenapa consumer Benson
cloned the first gene in the fly called
her or period this was really the
beginning of the whole field that was
providing an evidence for a genetic
significance of all possible means in
circadian biology and physiology most
recently these three fellows here you
see the Nobel Prize to understanding
because they understood in the clone and
identified by elements of the clock
system this field got the Nobel Prize
Zimmer Benson never did but I really
like to remember he is the guy that was
father behold now for me I just
mentioned that before all this started
in 1993 what we were doing at the time
we're studying this gene called cram and
I told you this fellow the first author
of this paper wanted to look at the
crime expression depending a gland
actually in the brain and find that is
real highly expressed in the night day
time this was a surprise at the time and
I felt something was wrong about the
experiment in reality it was fine
everything was fine just that what
happened to that postdoc was sacrificing
the mice at nighttime well the big
condition will surprise the mice during
day time I explained the difference
later on with the work with selma
schneider
in in our lab we worked in described
that in fact these are oscillation of
the creme de controls the in acetyl
transferase or serotonin that is
expressing opinion gland is the rate
limiting step in the production of the
hormone melatonin so all this was really
beginning to me was opening a whole new
world of excitement so let's go and see
what happens to our body
well everybody knows that we have an
oscillations of body temperature day
night the diluting cycle is dramatically
linked to securin cycle in fact wake up
in the morning because high levels of
cortisol right here it now is what give
us the desire of all food well in the
night we go to bed even fall asleep and
sleep is kept by the hormone melatonin
which I just mentioned that is a strong
economic if you look at possible all
possible hormones of interest in
everyone in their physiology and biology
they're all oscillating beautifully in a
day/night cycle what is even more
amazing to me is that the number just a
number of cells in the blood which
resides monocytes and so on is also
oscillating beautiful just the number of
cells which just tells you a lot about
how pervasive in importance the clock
system so the circular clock to the
world sukadeva told you from Latin about
24-hour cycles these are present all the
way from plants to animals fungi and
bacteria insects whatever you like but
it really is something extremely present
in the life-forms now those cycles are
as I said transcend but you have as I
gave us this is now a German word that
means time giver Tigers Tigers would do
things to readjust the clock every time
they can let's say you travel never
jetlag your normal intrinsic cycle is
out of phase with the light-dark cycle
in Europe for example that is what I
give her light will do will reset the
clock to allow that to be fixed every
day this happens also to listen now the
subpoena Clarkson molecular machinery
I'll show that very briefly it's based
on the transcription and translation
loops there are beautifully a conserved
even among species and many times the
clock genes would be loud as it said per
was the first one in the fly it's about
20 years other
being cloned indentified o'clock female
cry and so on and the key thing here is
that they are controlling a large number
of genes but we call clock control genes
of suji's the number of genes controlled
by this system of the transcription
system
he's extremely elevated because the
clock of female activators on a site on
the genome called
box the most common promoter element on
the gia what are the clocks the central
clock is in the brain the place called
suprachiasmatic ridiculous this is a
part of the object Alamos this Sen
received signals directly from the
retinal eye photonic tracked in the
retina where specialized cells using
some photos after skooled melanopsin
they received the light signal and it
was send a signal to the ACN this is the
central part of the clock is the master
clock and the die gabber light is able
to readjust the central clock as I said
during the season certain changes in
day/night cycle the kiddies current the
field was a few years ago 15 years ago
where my lab opposed to many other
friends and colleagues lab we discovered
the reflector really dark locks
everywhere the clocks in the heart in
the spleen liver in the muscle every
single cell has a single terminal to
qiyam clock and the questions been over
the years what are the moral signals
that are able to connect the central
clock to the box
can we somehow uncouple concentric lock
from the from the political bloc's
listen we can do that by what we call
the restricted feeling or even exercise
we have a bunch of beautiful stories
published or actually press about
exercise and about feigning other at the
time to go to new details running by the
people to go and look at those
publications and then that very same so
this is a bit of the central clock
system at the molecular level you see
the activators clock and emailed it back
to this it boxes the most common or
element do you know
they described thousands and thousands
of genes among those genes they're also
the genes called luring cry when cry
also part of the clock system in clock
central core mechanism yet what they do
they generate repressors parent cry our
oppressors of their own transcription as
well in transcription of many other
applauded control dude
these are solicitude day and night is
really booming activation and repression
of all these genes leading into the
control output in some big cycle for
neural oscillations body temperature
cell cycle melatonin 10 to 6 and
metabolism in feeling rhythms again I
don't have the time to go through all
these details but suffice to say for
example to the cell cycle this
oscillation is owned by Atocha Kimura
several years ago this system controls
to do we want kinase that is controlling
you g2m transition in the south side
this is a system it's present all south
and this is a simple array of
transcriptomics of genes you can see
this I gave her this is time in the
liver different time of the circadian
cycle and consume here along the cycle
every four hours we collect samples and
we done transcriptomics you see these
beautiful oscillations of genes visual
way isn't the expression it is really
remarkable and is talking touching
passes it doesn't you know though the
question we had in lab this was by a
crippled stock masala dough in the lab
about 10-12 years ago was afraid this
amazing oscillation of all those genes
we must have also the possibility of
chromatin remodeling at the same time it
must happen so what the Mossad did was a
taking a tamale recognized clean ionic
f-14 on each detail I told you those are
platforms for transcriptional in
silencing
signals to specific sites in the genome
mazaa found is that that particular our
situation is oscillating on
in Saco as I shown here you only
discovered that the protein clock that
is interested activators as also a hat
function is also was at the transferees
capacity in their minds a while later on
another great postdoc from Japan and as
Nakata the question if walk is a writer
what could be the corresponding eraser
and so you had to play the choice about
possible Easton deacetylases opinion
that there is a circadian incident as it
releases and yeah I'm gonna go quickly
here but he showed that um is certain
things in this class of the class stream
of HDX is the class to it now this class
is a particularly interest for many
reasons money is that um what still to
unless a suit one does one of the two in
family members is to remove us little
groups from a significant sister no no
least importance by doing so they
generate nicotine made it is another
important metabolite so twine what it
does is to consume any D but nad is
required for just one enzymatic function
so what we do here is that in order to
get the acetylation of a specific
protein we need to connect directly
energy with Tabassum energy metabolism
to any type of possible
downstream effect which is also on the
genome thereby search one connects
metabolism to epigenetics uh it was
consumed by other colleagues that indeed
suit one activities went to aging
metabolism inflammation even cellar
differentiation so what we discovered is
in brief this is really work many years
is that there's a good complex that is
for transcription of active our clock
genes that is responsible for the
increase in transcription in the
beginning of the phase this is a complex
it contains the activities can be now
things also additional phrases is also
due to transfer is called MLL one
another have the time to tell you about
this particular
he's on great interest this drives h3k4
trimethylation it's also very much
cyclic
when there's another complex and this is
just one complex that binds all htaccess
demethylases and consumes nad in this
response room by the acetylation of
histones and thereby from the down
regulation of gene expression
all this was great but then the question
was where nad comes from and entity
comes from the tryptophan pathway which
is meaning food it also comes from the
NAD savage bathroom it is basically
equivalent and present all the way from
east - well the Asif and is that nad is
oscillating as an as a metabolite
feeding it to us - one activity and
becomes oscillating itself so this was
beautiful because it seems to connect
this particular metabolic cycle the
transcription start now the key thing is
that nad is consumed by some tools by
consuming that makes nickel cinnamon and
in order to get back to nad you need
several enzymes among which this one
particularly called nicotine will be the
phosphorus and transferring well we
found that an empty p as a gene is
controlled by the clock system because I
see boxes in the coma so it is a
beautiful system where transcriptionally
an empty piece cyclic cyclic sitting of
the enzyme at least the cyclic function
in activity of nad
the name is consumed in a cyclic manner
by nad consuming enzymes for example so
turns were also other such as parts so
these are linking really beautifully
epigenetics to metabolism in a circadian
system so the question is when you
somehow going break this when you do
something bad to the clock system what
happens
well we discover by epigenetic I sorry I
pivot epidemiological studies were also
in the mouse then if you disrupt the
clock you of course create saamiya also
depression anxiety for example fellows
from finland are
forced to use the light therapy during
the winter time to fix their clock
system clock mutations in the mass wells
in the humans create metabolic disorders
inflammation accelerate aging obesity
diabetes even cancer suffice to say
there are ladies and work a night shift
and everybody they have a disruption of
the normals for keeping a clock system
will have 36 percent increases risk for
breast cancer so much that the
government of any mark has found that
this is actually a little risk for
breast cancer
alright so when you do that when you
disrupt the clock you stop the clock
when you look at your computer at 2:00
in the morning or TV set or you just
either Facebook or you simply respond to
the tundra viewer this is what happens
to you in disrupt your normal routine
eczema the fast luck the United States
and the everyone's Angeles where I live
the America
has increased by 254 not their fault
20:54 in the past 50 years that is what
happened as a stick of dynamite
normal 13-inch circuits establish a
million years of evolution another way
to disrupt the clock is food everybody
knows that important what eat in the
mouth she did but I also put when II we
summarize this thoughts and this revi
would get Asher was cell a couple of
years ago but if you look now this is a
perfect experiment these two mice in
spines are homozygous having the same
genotype never spread the same guy I'm
talking about the same number tabular
calories the only difference is that
this fella here will spread at the right
time of day Australia at the wrong time
of day has to say I mean if you feed
yourself like a cheeseburger at midnight
has a completely different effect itself
a cheeseburger midnight but this clearly
indicated that the food interaction with
a normal circular clock was remarkable
it has very deep consequences for our
physiology the tablet
so we embarked into this and really
believe into this image this Italian
painter from five centuries ago was
showing the rain that you know we are
really what we eat this is a quote from
a German philosopher further back and we
really believe that who we decide to
society is in more detail and I'll show
you a couple examples in the next couple
songs so what we did was really to look
how how our normal metabolism and with
some other diets we've done several
experiments and I'm not gonna be the
time to show you all them but here there
are a couple papers showing that when we
discover is that the clock system has
the capacity to reprogram itself and it
does this through epigenetic control so
this is a classical design study that
has been reproduced now in my lab for
other ways and I'll tell you in a minute
what I'm talking about so what we take
away the mice were fed either a normal
child or a high-fat diet for the
high-fat diet we done this over ten
weeks the last day we select samples
from a number of tissues liver muscle
serum and so on and what we do after
this is to do transcriptomics and
metabolomics all those tissues now I
don't have the time again to go through
all those data but just to say that
either can imagine to adapt this same
designer study also for ketogenic diet
also for fasting also for caloric
restriction where do we have on growing
a beautiful study on alcohol consumption
as well now what happens to specifically
let's just look at the genes I don't
have the time to go to many details but
let's look at the genes for some time
for a second that shows you the amazing
capacity of the heart to be flexible in
the response to food so this is now
array again and you see this is the
normal type of oscillation genes in the
liver no way we call normal child
parents here this is someone who's
eating healthy food now if you eat a
cheeseburger too many times a day or too
many times in a week this what happens
thousands of genes that oscillation the
normal oscillations are completely gone
so what you're really doing is
disrupting normal clock system instead
what you do this is now another task
there's a different manner from our
panel another tangent aluminum not
oscillating hardly but they start to
oscillate dramatically and I ever died
it shows you that the plot is not only
disrupted in its normal function is able
to be reprogrammed by I should die or
different types of the clock itself
instant as the capacity to adapt to a
new cycle depending on the what is that
to do and we can go back from back and
forth in these two systems if we put the
animal back normal child
they will regain this type of
oscillation quite quickly to tell you
again the amazing capacity from both
prescription also ap jailing system or
the clock reorganizing alright so what
we did recently we've done we are
applied this in tap logic here but we
applied after metabolomics we've done a
study that is recently published in cell
where we took virus tissues a while ago
station brown adipose tissue sperm
muscle liver but also to ears in the
brain
yes CN in the prefrontal cortex what we
did was look at how many metabolites
will oscillate in a single tissue in how
much those oscillation would be affected
by high fat diet and the results are
staggering really remarkable you can see
some down here about how differently
these oscillations are in different
organs however what we can see by in the
surface blonde with a large number of
metabolites are somehow able to show
connections coordination and
communication between different tissues
mr. Clark's initial issues specifically
serum talks to well to muscle and
adipose tissue no much too
while it was tissue the two brain areas
despite the fact they have lots of
metabolites oscillating you know really
talk to each other in all these
connections all this communication
implant is dramatically disrupted never
died so what happens when you do a
nutritional challenge not only disrupt
the physiology which is in organ but
rather we didn't is to somehow impact
the possible connections between the
traditions and this goes to a general
concept which is the concept of
Dominican clocks on which we working
really hard right now specifically by
designing a new type of mouse models and
we believe that this logic will also
lead to a better outcome for human
physiology in understanding better how
humans really should adapt to different
types of certain cycle when I give walks
without exception a and asked by several
people in the audience whether to eat
the morning or night how much this
should sleep or not the reality what we
propose is that we need to go to a wide
population by profiling using schools
hospitals athletes and by doing a
metabolomic and epigenomic filing we'll
go through a solution which is like the
seamy the practice of personalized
medicine which at the end the best thing
to do is not only to cure but to prevent
this will definitely helped also the
fact that the cost of healthcare is
increasing dramatically in our society
is through the profiling just like the
one I showed you here for the mouse and
we can now in humans we already doing
any athletes in some other patients we
can definitely tell that there are
specific metabolic signatures there are
determining in defining either normal
good physiology or some pathological
oxygen
I like to stop here now if that's okay
with you
okay and I know if you have questions
you go go ahead yeah you can just um
just just you can take it off the
PowerPoint presentation the screen sir
all right yeah here we go
it was it was pretty nice like it gives
you overall view of the whole the
connection between different things and
on too much into details because I felt
that would have been maybe distracting
so I decided to do something general
useful yeah I have a one question
basically like yeah I think you are
planning on doing these things like what
happens with the humans is basically
like there's people who are working
night shifts for a long period of time
but there are like other for me like I
watch some football or soccer or
something like that cricket like during
some time like in the middle of the
night sure I shouldn't do that so but
the thing is that yeah like if I switch
back and forth
you should then watch in the morning
after the thing is number one what we
have found just not just NEMA many
colleagues as well is that restricted
feeding is probably the best thing you
can do to your body in terms of allowing
or permitting a better synchronisation
of all those claws nobody really does is
to quit walks into some type of the same
wavelength
the other thing that we found we were
just the paper isn't been accepted
recently guys gonna come out soon Cell
Metabolism this shows how exercise as
well is critical in how the time of
exercise is critical when is the most
beneficial time for exercise studies a
bit time for everything we do and it's
not matter to that you shouldn't do
something really bad happens to you but
if instead you do something wrong which
is they say every night until 2:00 in
the morning
watching TV or eating big ice cream at
2:00 in the morning if you do that one
time it's fine but if more you do it
more you install this new clock what
you're really doing you reprogram
yourself still apparently have a normal
lifestyle but what you're doing you're
dating all those pathways of
inflammatory responses in shock
responses in stress responses in the
body and then in the long term can
generate a pathologist and that's why
we're interested in the relationship
between metabolism and epigenetics
because those pathological situations
are probably installed through some type
of cellular memory there has to work on
the epigenome okay and the one more
thing like that is like you are talking
about Clark and exercise foot but
exercise food and all those things are
related to aging - let's try so you look
at me when she said that if you take B
Mel B Mel as a key protein of the clock
system B mal no Carmine's
have accelerated aging so clearly if you
touch the clock system you do and do
something with the paper in cell about a
year and a half ago where we
demonstrated that aging works through
the zucchini reprogramming of metabolic
functions mostly any D energy metabolism
mostly through a situation you can
revert you can actually rejuvenate
somehow the system by simply in doing
caloric restriction not a huge carcass
which maybe 30% it's enough to risk
let's say somehow revert the aging
phenotype on the clock system so the
clock functions better and there's an
increase in acetylation capacity by
simple research in color research okay
that's interesting so I need to go back
and look at that paper so so thank you
so much I really appreciate your
apprecia to doing this look forward to
your other papers coming out pretty soon
right so thank you so much
we'll be on our website pretty soon so I
send you the link you can distribute it
to your people like put it in your web
page or whatever you want to do all
right thank you so much thank you
Cheers bye